there is either an Ebola outbreak that
will end human society or not that big
of a deal happening right now it depends
who you're listening to so we wanted to
break down some facts for you so right
now in western Africa they are having
the worst Ebola outbreak that they've
ever had there have been about 930
deaths and about 1,700 cases and this is
going on in Sierra Leone Liberia and
Nigeria and we've got some more info for
you the disease spreads via bodily
fluids so it is not airborne we got to
just put that out there right now
because that's what a lot of people are
afraid of the death count has grown to
887 as of August 4th so I was just
giving you the updated numbers with a
total of about 1600 likely diagnosed
victims so far the fatality rate from
this outbreak has been about 60% which
could rise to about 90% and right now
there is no vaccine for Ebola though the
World Health Organization reports that
there are several being tested and let's
look at a timeline of what's going on
here the first Ebola epidemic was in
1976 and disease killed 280 people which
was 88% of the people who became
infected ok so now let's bring this back
to America for a second so we had two
doctors over there that were treating
people with Ebola and they got affected
infected with Ebola they are now in
Atlanta at the CDC and they are
quarantined so we'll see what happens
with that people have been freaking out
Donald Trump where who I get all my
information from he is on Twitter
freaking out about why are we bringing
these people back again it is not
airborne but I don't have any great
faith in the government that they're not
going to somehow screw this up and make
it airborne
who knows we will see but before we get
into all the specifics let's just look
at a little info on what Ebola actually
does
okay so symptoms typically begin four to
nine days after exposure though the
incubation period could last for up to
21 days the first couple days days one
through three
you have flu-like symptoms and profound
weakness days four through seven
patients may also have vomiting diarrhea
nausea low blood pressure headaches and
anemia day seven through ten toward the
end of the illness there's confusion and
bleeding
both internal and visible all of this
progresses toward coma shock and death
okay so pretty bad stuff kara clean up
all the science messes that I create so
I'm not even going to give you a
question I'm just going to talk cleanup
mode yes so first and foremost the
earliest outbreak ever of Ebola was in
central Africa obviously physicians have
never seen Ebola so they weren't sure
how to contain it that's why the death
toll was as high as it was and that's
why the actual rate of people dying
versus people getting infected was
nearly 90 percent now that is the the
number that a lot of people are citing
now Ebola you know has a 90% death rate
but what we're seeing in West Africa now
is actually closer to 60% what we would
see in America if Ebola took hold here
would be significantly lower because we
have significantly better health
practices than we're seeing in those
regions so that's number one
to remember a lot of people are really
really afraid of these two physicians
coming over - they're actually an Emory
in an Emory hospital all right so I
think the the thing was built by the
Seattle
CDC is like right next door so they've
got a lot of CDC influence there there
is very very very minimal risk of
anybody else getting infected these
individuals are heavily quarantined
there are so many safeguards being taken
Ebola is very easily killed by
disinfectants cleaning up after an
individual is a very easy way to prevent
transmission of the disease it's
actually quite hard to catch one way
that a lot of physicians will tell you
to think about Ebola is think about it
like HIV so you can catch HIV from
transmission of bodily fluids from blood
from semen from saliva if there's blood
in the saliva it's very hard to catch
HIV by shaking somebody's hand by
sitting on the same you know train as
them Ebola is very similar in that way
so I think that's a really important
thing for people to realize that they
don't often yes away people talking
about that that was pretty much
so I wanted you to clean it up and then
that was what I was gonna say to you is
I want it to do this segment because
this isn't what people are talking about
if you turn on the news you know
pandemic freaked out everything yeah and
of course that's what the news is
trained us to do so what is this just
the nature of the news it's 20 years ago
we got great people out at all cost yeah
I think so they can keep watching yeah
why like if they thought oh who all is
well they're gonna turn their
televisions off and then just go about
their day yeah so you know they want to
sit in front of it they want to see like
the craziness ensue and and and they
want to keep people watching so they
just they don't tell us that yeah thank
you yeah what are you I think one thing
also that's important to remember is
that I mean 1,600 people is an out brand
like this is dangerous but Ebola is not
what you read in hot zone yeah you know
it didn't work out that well for a day
it really didn't she yeah she died in
the end and here's the thing if you were
an aid worker in West Africa in Sierra
Leone in Nigeria not my Geryon Nigeria
there's only one case and it's not even
a confirmed Ebola case or maybe it's two
but that was that was the big initial
fears that it spread to Nigeria which is
actually a large populated country in in
the capital there but Sierra Leone and
Guinea and where else is in West Africa
Liberia exactly these are less populated
areas the reason that you see this huge
jump between 1976 and and now is that
they are more urbanized more people can
get on planes so there are people who
have access to moving around Africa that
they didn't have before and also
distrust of Western medicine has spiked
in West Africa and what we're seeing is
that the aid workers are going in and
they're saying you may be infected
they're taking family members away and
the family members are coming back in
body bags and this is very frightening
to these individuals also it's customary
in Africa that in death rituals they
actually wash the bodies and this is a
really easy way to transmit the disease
and so a lot of people are catching it
and they're not listening to the council
that says you cannot come in contact
with the infected it's the only way
that's right so you've given us a lot of
the heavy lifting here I of course
watched the first episode of the strain
last night which didn't help my paranoia
at all because that's pretty much all
it's about so all right now that we've
gotten sort of the factual part of it so
let's let's go with the fun jump part of
it is the contagion part in the outbreak
part do you think one day that that
stuff is eventually going to end up here
like those movies I love both of those
movies do you think that that's sort of
not with this specifically but it could
somehow it could become something could
be a form of terrorism in a way if
somebody wanted to do that they could
use it as a form of terrorism I actually
I wanted to ask like I had heard that
there is a serum that is working because
they're saying that there's no vaccine
but now they do have a serum that seems
to be working they shipped it over to
Africa
what is it what is that well here's the
here's the issue here there are a lot of
treatments that are in the works that we
know might work on organisms that aren't
human you know that way we can have an
Ebola a type of Ebola in a pig or in a
monkey and then we're going to you know
we're gonna try and treat it and there
have been really big strides that have
been made in the lab unfortunately this
is a big sticking point for a lot of
people because if we do go into these
countries and we do try a treatment that
ends up either failing or that ends up
having some sort of horrible side effect
that distrust is going to spike even
more and so what we know now is the best
way to treat Ebola is to quarantine the
victims the victims may die they may not
depending on how strong their immune
systems are but if you quarantine them
you won't see any more spread of the
disease
that's the number one thing to do as far
as a pandemic an epidemic that could
take out human I mean it'd be so good
yeah we've seen it with bubonic plague
we've known it with Spanish flu we've
seen like horrible horrible diseases
that we didn't understand at that point
that we didn't know how to contain and I
don't think it's that unlikely a
scenario that's something like that
could happen of course medicine has
grown leaps and bounds it's a really
good book by David Kwan called spillover
that's all about this and I recommend it
to anybody who who reads still there's
probably an audio book but I would say
that my bigger fear I agree with it it
would be weaponizing
types of diseases in order to make them
difficult to treat and in order to make
them heavily transmissible it would be
yeah yeah yeah it would be engineered so
alright so last thought on this Lu
finish up is how much can we pay
attention to this stuff man you know it
man like you can worry about the
specifics of this yeah and then you can
worry about the terror and all or all
that how much brain power are you giving
this stuff on on a day-to-day basis I
think I just check in daily check the
news kind of like you know click on
things and and I think that's all you
can do you just kind of like educate
yourself and then don't freak out about
it I mean that's that's what they want
you to do they want you to live in and
still fear in you so that you freak out
and you keep watching the news all day
long and and it's know just like educate
yourself and move on and let the fear go
all right well yeah don't listen to
Donald Trump alright well I hope we did
a little bit of what Nicki just said
right there so that you got some facts
that maybe you won't be freaking out but
you know a little something and you can
do a little more research and Kari you
get a gold